StStéphanie Grammond, Michel
DaDavid, Michel C. Auger, qu'es-
cece qui arrive avec nos ponts e
5555 ou 58 ans? Pont Champlain i
n'n'a même pas vécu 58 ans. Le
popont
popont important, pour sortir de
MoMontréal, pour rentrer, à
l'l'ouest, et là, il est,
sosolidarité, il est totalement
fefermé, on laissait déjà entrer
vevers les, c'est terminé, il et
fefermé. Un petit mot, je sais e
vovous aimez ces sujets, pourqui
leles ponts bâtis il y a 55 ans,
çaça ne fonctionne plus?
- - Un mot : entretien. Si le pt
ChChamplain avait été entretenu
cocomme du monde, c'est encore ,
onon l'a accepté au moment où oa
vuvu sa pont qu'on a dû le ferm,
quque l'entretien avait été mal
fafait, il avait été mal destiné
auaussi à cause de lui, mais c't
unune question d'entretien. C'et
unune question d'entretien, et e
miministère des Transports, il
fafaut le dire, fait une assez
mamauvais travail quand il s'agt
d'd'entretenir ses
ininfrastructures.
- - Vous n'êtes pas obligé.
- - Les ponts, c'est le même
prproblème avec l'écoute, avec s
hhôpitaux, il y a eu une espèce
dede palmarès du mauvais entretn
ququi a été présenté récemment,
dedes fois, ça a des conséquencs
cacatastrophiques, on se souviet
totous du viaduc, du pont de la
CoConcorde, au vraiment la ville
ilil y avait eu mort, deux ou
trtrois morts, alors c'est ce qe
MiMichel dit, c'est qu'on n'a ps
enentretenu, d'une à l'autre, iy
a a d'autres priorités, toujours
ququelque chose de plus importa.
- - Je travaille à Ottawa, j'ai
fafait trop souvent, Montréal-
otottawa, il n'y avait que des
trtravaux sur sa pont, tout le
tetemps, on l'a élargi à un momt
dodonné, il y a quelque chose de
mymystérieux dans ma tête.
- - Je dirais quand même Michel
didisais, il y a un difficile
d'd'entretien, c'est pas seulemt
popour les ponts. Québec fait un
bibilan et puis on voit qu'il ya
unune vaste... un vaste parc
d'd'actifs qui sont dans un état
pipitoyable au Québec, ce qui et
mamalheureux, c'est que quand on
tatarda faire l'entretien, plusa
vava que ça coûte cher, donc ce
seserait logique de faire les
trtravaux au fur et à mesure
plplutôt que de toujours réparer
cocomme on l'a vu avec le pont
ChChamplain vous a coûté des
fofortunes, alors qu'on sait qun
ététait déjà obligé de bâtir un
nonouveau pont. On est dans une
sisituation où on a des qu'on
ararrange un peu partout, alors
llà, on a une pénurie de main-
d'd'oeuvre, tout coûte cher, doc
onon essaie de rattraper, mais
c'c'est pas évident.
- - Si l'image en direct.
- - On ne peut pas mettre ça sur
lele dos d'une chicane
prprovinciale-fédérale.
- - Quelqu'un nous a volé un mot
trtrès drôle en disant : on veut
unun tunnel, on fait un tunnel!
- - Mais le béton, c'est peut-êe
papas si bon que ça non plus.
ReRegardez le très beau pont
JaJacques-Cartier qui est encore
tototalement fonctionnel et qui
n'n'est pas fait en béton.
- - Qui est Dieu et qui est dro.
- - Il décroche...
- - c'est à cause d'une
exexpropriation, quelqu'un n'a s
vovoulu laisser son terrain, c't
popour ça qu'on a dû faire une
cocourbe dans le pont. OK, les
frfrontières, parlons de choses
blbloqué, conduit d'un autre mo,
esest-ce qu'il y aura pas de pls
enen plus de pression pour qu'on
rorouvre, qu'on assouplisse ce i
sese passe ça l'a frontière
cacanado-américaine?
- - C'est clair que ça va devenr
unun ange, plus la campagne de
vavaccination aime avance et pls
l'l'été approche parce que pour
l'l'industrie touristique, pour
l'l'industrie du transport aéri,
c'c'est évidemment des sommes
imimportantes qui sont en jeu,
alalors si on obtient des
rérésultats encourageants du côé
dede la vaccination de c'est sûr
quque plus on va aller, et plusn
ilil va y avoir de la pression
paparce que les gens vont voulor
pepeut-être sortir pour l'été,
alaller sur les plages du mail,
etetc., mais on est encore autor
dede 40 % à la fois au Canada et
auaux États-Unis, c'est
inintéressant de le dire on est
prpratiquement nez à nez parce e
leles Américains nous avaient un
pepeu nargué en disant qu'on étt
enen retard, mais donc, presquea
momoitié de la population est
vavaccinée première dose de pard
auautre. Sauf que là, le
gogouvernement Trudeau semblait
didire qu'il faudrait qu'on soit
7575 % plutôt pour ouvrir les
frfrontières, alors il y a encoe
unun grand bout de chemin à fai.
EtEt aux États-Unis, on voit qul
y y a plus de récalcitrants, doc
esest-ce qu'ils vont réussir à
alaller chercher l'adhésion?
MaMalgré le fait qu'ils offrent
totoutes sortes de cadeaux pour
coconvaincre les gens d'aller se
fafaire vacciner. Je pense que
ulultimement, ça va passer peut-
êêtre par un passeport vacaccin,
c'c'est une solution qui se metn
brbranle à l'échelle mondiale,
dodonc est-ce que notre preuve
ququ'on est supposé avoir sur
nonotre téléphone cellulaire va
êêtre la clé qui va permettre
d'd'ouvrir des frontières? C'est
papas possible.
- - Il y a beaucoup de gens qui
didisent qu'on ne peut pas faire
trtrois ou quatre mois encore
cocomme ça.
- - J'ai l'impression que c'este
dedernier rapport, j'ai comme le
sesentiment qu'à partir du 21
jujuin, les frontières vont
ououvrir, comme disait Stéphani,
ilil y a beaucoup de gens qui
atattendent de se lancer à Old
OrOrchard ou de faire du
mamagasinage à Place Bell. Ils
sosont quand même en avant sur a
dedeuxième dose des États-Unis,l
fafaut dire que c'est très inégl
auaussi, les étapes frontaliersu
QuQuébec, la vaccination va plut
bibien, mais il y a d'autres...
lala situation aux États-Unis,
dadans des états républicains, n
paparticulier, ça va moins bien.
- - Le virus est toujours là, on
vava dire que c'est pas si mal,
c'c'est sous contrôle....
ilil faudrait voir si les
AmAméricains sont prêts à ouvrir
leleurs frontières aussi parce e
çaça se joue à deux et les deux
gogouvernements peuvent apporter
l'l'un ou l'autre des
cocomplications à ça. On a le
GoGoodale dans le Maine, mais
c'c'est peut-être pas le cas des
rerestaurateurs de Plattsburgh,e
nene sais pas, tout est plus
cocompliqué quand il y a deux
jojoueurs.
- - On verra pour les règles de
ququarantaine, est-ce qu'ils
seseront assoupis ou pas, il y a
dedes gens qui voyaient en Euroe
etet vont revenir, M. Trudeau va
paparler demain, on verra demai.
PaPar ailleurs, est-ce que le
fifinancement du tunnel va dever
lala prochaine chicane fédérale-
prprovinciale?
- - J'ai l'impression que oui.
EnEncore que il y a un contexte
élélectoral qui va peut-être,
didisons, amener les gens à mete
dede parted autre de l'eau dans
leleur vin, mais là, le
gogouvernement fédéral, je pens,
esest assis sur une position asz
sosolide, aux dernières nouvell,
ilils accepteraient de financera
papartie traransport en commun u
prprojet, c'est-à-dire
esessentiellement deux voies
d'd'autobus dans le tunnel, ce i
rereprésenterait à peu près 10 %
susur 10 milliards, ça fait pas
bebeaucoup, si on compare par
exexemple avec le tramway de
QuQuébec, où le gouvernement du
QuQuébec finance jusqu'à 40 %.
C'C'est clair que le gouvernemet
Legault va être déçu, fâché,
mamais je pense que l'opinion
pupublique à l'extérieur de la
rérégion de Québec va trouver qe
lele gouvernement fédéral à une
bobonne cause là-dedans, que ce
tutunnel ne devrait pas être
coconstruit et encore moins
fifinancé par des programmes qui
sosont en principe destiné à des
ininfrastructures vertes.
- - C'est que ça ne rentre pas
dadans un programme de transport
cocollectif, le gros rentre de
l'l'addition, alors qu'est-ce
ququ'on fait? Les consommateurs
onont déjà dit aujourd'hui dansa
rérégion de Québec : on va vous
aiaider, vous aiderez.
- - Bien sûr, on va voir des
cocomtés, c'est pour ça qu'on va
sese retrouver avec le tunnel
paparce que M. Legault la premir
popour avoir des comtés dans la
rérégion de Québec, comme jadis,
etet de toute façon, à Québec, a
momoitié des gens n'en veulent
papas, à Lévis, tout le monde on
veveut par exemple. Mais la
réréalité, c'est qu'il n'y a rin
ququi justifie 10 milliards
d'd'investissements pour 55 000
vovoitures, c'est une estimation
dede M. Bonnardel, beaucoup de
gegens disent que c'est trop.
C'C'est la moitié de ce qui pase
susur le pont Pierre Laporte, on
pepeut pas justifier 10 milliars
dede dollars, et le gouvernement
féfédéral va avoir des amis à de
nonon à Québec parce que rajoutr
unune voie réservée à des autob,
c'c'est pas offrir un projet de
trtransport en commun, ce n'est
papas vrai.
- - Je pense que c'est ça, c'est
unun peu de la poudre aux yeux
paparce qu'on s'entend que c'est
popour faire circuler des
vovoitures, on a dit que ce sera
dedes voitures électriques un
jojour, mais quand même, ce n'et
papas un projet de relance vert,
papas du tout, c'est plutôt un
prprojet qui va amener encore ps
d'd'automobilistes sur les routs
paparce qu'on sait que quand on
auaugmente la capacité, quand on
crcrée des ponts, les autoroutes
quque ça fait juste amener pluse
vévéhicules, donc de l'étalement
ururbain, donc de la pollution.n
a a un gouvernement qui nous
prpromet une relance verte, ce
n'n'est pas dans cette direction
llà que ça s'en va. Il y aurait
dedes solutions de transport en
cocommun possible, salaire
loloufoque, mais la possibilitée
fafaire un téléphérique entre Ly
etet Québec, c'est quand même
ququelque chose qui peut être
exexploré. Ça coûterait infinimt
momoins cher, ça prendrait moins
dede temps à mettre en place, ça
trtransporterait plus de
pepersonnes. Moins d'auto, pour
l'l'auto, certain que c'est mois
prpratique. Mais par contre, ce
seserait du transport en communt
leles gens qui prendraient ce
tétéléphérique des engagerait ls
poponts parcrce que il ne serait
plplus sur les routes.
- - Je ne pense pas qu'on vivre
asassez vieux pour voir M. Legat
anannonçait un téléphérique ente
LéLévy et Québec.
VoVous avez réagi.
- - Les téléphérique, quand on
plplante, dans un congrès
d'd'urbanisme, et j'en rigole un
pepeu parce que ce n'est pas trs
prpratique, ça casse, Dalibaire,
susur le fleuve, ce ne sera pas
trtrès agréable. Je ne suis pas
ssûr que ça peut remplacer un
vrvrai système de transport en
cocommun. Cela dit, on peut bien
esessayer d'autres choses, mais
ririen ne justifie le tunnel.
- - Est-ce que néanmoins, M.
TrTrudeau n'est pas un peu embêé
paparce que là, ça va devenir ue
prpression énorme, M. Duclos a
réréagi aujourd'hui, on va le
momontrer, aucun projet officiel
n'n'a encore été présenté au
gogouvernement fédéral pour
ananalyse. Il y a un peu d'iron,
nonous avons hâte, écrit-il, M.
DuDuclos.
LeLe transport collectif.
N'N'est-il pas quand même un peu
emembêté, M. Trudeau, parce que
llà, il y a des élections qui se
popointent le nez, dire non à
QuQuébec.
- - Je pense que M. Trudeau a ue
bobonne position, d'abord, Michl
LaLardy, à Québec, les gens sont
papartagés, ce n'est pas sur la
ririve sud que M. Trudeau espère
fafaire des gains et d'autre pa,
lele bloc, vous savez, a été trs
titimide là-dedans. Au début, is
onont dit : ça regarde Québec, t
onon est satisfait de voir qu'iy
a a des équipements vers là-
dededans, mais tout le monde vot
quque c'est de la foutaise, il y
a a pas vraiment d'équipement
vevert. Mais juste pour revenir
susur la question du téléphériqe
quque ça peut paraître un peu
loloufoque, mais je me souviens
quque Jean Garon à l'époque
prproposer un métro et je rentrs
dede me demander si on n'aurait
papas dû l'écouter.
- - Déjà, Jean Garon voulait un
mémétro?
- - Tout à fait, mais un tunnele
trtransport en commun, par un
tutunnel pour les voitures, il a
étété ridiculisé à l'époque, mas
àà bien y penser, ce n'est peut-
êêtre pas si vous.
- - Il aurait fallu le faire à e
momoment-là. Est-ce que vous
pepensez que finalement, compte
tetenu de tout ça, tout ce qu'on
enentend depuis quelques jours,
c'c'est pas possible que ça ne e
fafasse pas?
- - Bien, je pense que ce sera e
bobonne chose que ce n'est pas e
l'l'avant. Ce qui manque à Québ,
c'c'est du transport en commun,
papas des autoroutes, il est
tutunnel. Donc on le sait, Québ,
dede toutes les grandes villes
cacanadiennes, l'une de celle ùu
leles gens empruntent le moins s
trtransports en commun, c'est le
fifils apologues il y en a pas,
ilils ne peuvent pas le prendre,
mamais deux fois moins qu'à
MoMontréal, même moins qu'en
AlAlberta, à Calgary, Edmonton.
DoDonc, c'est là qu'il faut mete
lele paquet si on veut.
- - La vice-première ministre a
didit en conférence de presse
ququ'elle a annoncé le projet ac
M.M. Legault : vous ne comprenez
papas, des gens de Montréal, nos
avavons droit à notre part du
ggâteau de gros projets aussi.
- - Il y a beaucoup de projets r
lelesquels on pourrait investir,
mamais ça va se faire M. Legault
nene reculera pas là-dessus, çae
paparaît impensable, et c'est tp
enengagé, il s'est excusé une
cocouple de fois pour avoir fait
dedes erreurs, mais celle-là, je
pepense qu'il ne l'admettra
jajamais.
- - Tout projet qui tient sur
trtrois mandats de gouvernement
esest susceptible de... un momet
dodonné. David Ayres, M. Legault
s's'est avancé beaucoup trop sur
cece projet pour ne pas le fair.
LaLa seule chose qui peut arriv,
c'c'est que le gouvernement
féfédéral d'un titulaire d'arget
quque il va peut-être penser à
dedeux fois avant de mettre 9
mimilliards sur son propre projt
àà leurs clients notre qui
atattendent. C'est une histoire